all right christina yes christina where
did you grow up where are you from
originally originally i am from wichita
falls texas
and tell me about your family you had
mom and dad
um
i did
well i do my dad
um
was my
best friend a bit you know um
hard on all of us kids but
in the end you know he was always my
best friend i looked up to him and
wish that he would have done the same
you know
found comfort in who he was
but um
my mom
didn't like me much i don't think she
ever has
uh
i was born
um
in okinawa japan
to a military
um
upbringing that left
all of us i would say devastated in a
way you know um
my
[Music]
mom felt that she had to
uh
catered to
my dad in ways that she didn't want to i
think she got married out of
the fact that um
she wanted away from
the way she was living and thought that
getting with my dad would make it better
and things just got
i would say you know from
both perspectives so then
things got um
wrong like they knew that they loved
each other but not in a way that
intimate people would you know
they loved each other like best friends
and i think they're part of them
trying to love each other as spouses is
what they could never do right so um
they had
three kids i have a
older brother
a younger sister and a half sister now
and
um i um
was a middle kid
you know
trying to bounce between
you know trying to figure out if you
know i was supposed to play mom or
um
you know uh
just
try to figure out you know
how playing mom you know whenever i have
my own kids i do much better job at it
but um
i always had
dreams of
you know getting
married and you know having a happy life
and all that stuff it doesn't stay that
way you know especially if the one that
you
you know um admire doesn't like you back
no matter what you do or try to do for
him it'll never get better
so
i am
i've been married twice and neither one
of them ever worked out you know
i spent most of my time trying to
you know make someone
happy and it wouldn't be
you know
i live my life to take care of kids and
i did the best that i could regardless
of what they think of me now
you know um
in perspective
i put in
what i could with what i had you know
and um
i hope that
someday they'd be proud of me
and if they're not then
you know i know i did my best so
i try to be a perfect mom
and in the end it just
they'll honor you in their due time i
guess
you know
um
are you separated from your kids now
um i had to leave because of a
um
a really bad uh
the marriage was just really bad and i
had to get out of there you know and the
kids were getting about as bad as their
dad
you know and
just by witnessing what they saw they
thought it was normal
you know what did they see um
basically that i was just their
their slave and nothing more
you know i was the person that
cleaned and cooked and
you know um
was
you know treated less than you know by
everybody
the worst thing was you know
if my husband and i would argue he'd go
and wake up one of my kiddos and he was
like hey she's doing this this and this
you know and i had my
kiddo kind of
beat on me it was kind of sad you know
but um
they live by example i guess
and
um
i'm not
you know i miss them i love them but i
don't think that they would care you
know if i try to get a hold of them
anyway
so they're
i have six kids i have three girls and
three boys and grand baby
and how old are they now are they now
um one was born in 1995 and i've had
them every two years apart except for
the last one
he was um three years apart so yeah
they're
getting older
um
yeah
you've been homeless for how long for
going on three and a half four years now
it's a rough lifestyle out there
you know
you got to be careful who you
trust in who you don't you consider a
friend and
you know um
go with your gut rather than
you know what you're being told
and
you know it'd be a lesson that i
had to learn in
a hard way
where have you been homeless
i've been homeless in
denver colorado by choice one time
because living in my house was like a
prison
you know
i was like i'd rather be free outside
than
you know be a slave in my own house you
know
my nickname in there was alfred
you know and i was like well damn the
week alfred gets paid
you know i do everything i can here
i wasn't allowed to work
i wasn't allowed really to watch tv
um kind of like when i was younger i
guess when
they say you marry somebody like your
dad
that's what ended up happening even
though my dad hated who i married
but um but no physical abuse or sexual
abuse
um
there was a lot of physical abuse when i
was younger especially to my brother
and my sister
not really my sister as much
she was the baby of the family like
she knew to stay out of it you know but
finally my dad started getting so mad
that none of us would mess up if we did
something wrong
and he would spank all three of us to
make sure he got the guilty party you
know and we were like damn it we know it
was you you most time is my brother but
he um
he's our unsung hero you know
my i look up to him more than anyone in
the world like
i've never seen somebody get beaten so
bad you know
by their
own dad you know
come to find out
um
this is your father you're talking about
yeah i mean big and bad i remember one
time i had a
platon like those metal batons like back
in the day they weren't plastic or
nothing they were metal you know and
dad whapped him over the head with it
and i was like i did not think that
thing was supposed to bend
you know so who beat you here my dad
beat my brother oh your brother yeah
it was horrible it happened a lot you
know
mom
she would barely spank us at all but you
know as soon as my dad she'd be like
wait did your dad get some blah blah and
he'd have to spank us you know
for things that we did during the day
that we done forgot about you know
there's no lesson learned there you know
other than i hate my mom because you're
making my dad beat me
you know
and um i didn't really hate my mom i
i wanted her to love me i started doing
drugs because of my mom i wanted to fit
in with her i was like i'm tired of
being behind a closed door you know if i
start getting high you know doing what
you're doing maybe you'll let me in on
the other side
well
i started getting high with her and
i didn't like what i saw on the inside
you know about as much as i did whenever
i was shut out
spent a lot of time playing with the
kids no matter
you know where i was going or what i was
doing you know
i would
at least pay attention to the kids you
know so they got some bit of happiness
while
you know everybody's laying around doing
their thing you know
i've always
been more of a
i've cared for kids a lot you know and
and more child like myself than i should
be most time you know started out life
was shaking baby syndrome but i turned
it out i turned out fine i think
you know um
found out you know
my mom told me you know that my dad
shook me when i was a baby
she did it you know just to make me hate
my dad you know and i asked him i was
like dad did you do that and he's like
yeah he's like i'm sorry kiddo you know
and then found out that it wasn't even
him he took the blame for my mom
weird how things work out you know
um
the secrets that you can find out when
someone's gone which is just crazy
but
i'm proud of um
mainly
my uncle
i looked up to him more than anything in
the world more than he would ever
imagine
i love my uncle
because i loved him more than anything i
wished he could have been my dad at
times i was like
he was
the first person that i told that i
like
i was like i like girls and he's like no
no
no
you don't want to have to be in that
lifestyle and i was like okay
you know told my
ex the same thing and
he seemed to like girls too just
wouldn't let me be the same way you know
bit hypocritical the way the world goes
it's crazy
then you know honest with somebody
and you know tell them what you truly
feel they'll lie straight to your face
and you know walk off in your closet and
be like oh
you know
if you could have just
been real with me the whole time you
know
so
i went through most of my life um
wishing that i would have married a girl
um
but i guess that moment will come when i
get there you know find the right person
that seriously wants to put a ring
around my finger forever
you know
that'll be a good day
but until then you know i guess i do
what i gotta do
and i'll find my little bits of
happiness wherever i go
until
you know
i enjoy
being with someone that really does love
and
respect me back no matter what i'm doing
or
you know
no matter
who i like you know so what i like a
girl you know
and
you know sometimes i like both you know
it's just being biased a
weird
instance to be in you're like one second
you know i want you to
love me forever and another person's
like well i thought
you know
that i'd be enough for you
and
but once i get there and somebody really
does want to put a ring on my finger
forever
happiness is just what i'm trying to
find
you know i'm experimenting with drugs
and trying to find the happiness in that
world
it comes in brief moments
but
when you finally find that one
i'm still looking forward to that drugs
been a part of your life for a long time
yeah i started when i was um
it was my 15th my 15th birthday actually
with my mom
and i was kind of excited you know that
she wanted me to do it with her i
finally felt like i was part of the
in-crowd you know all my friends would
hang out with my parents you know and i
couldn't figure out why you know i was
too fat i hated the way i looked as a
kid you know everybody else around was
so skinny and you know they didn't eat
and you know all this stuff and i'm like
what's wrong with me i'm almost [ __ ]
hungry and that you know i hated my
my um
being a kiddo you know i really did i've
never felt pretty
in my entire life i never have
um
my dad used to call me pigpen which was
a good
a good nickname
you know
and very fawcett minor would call me
you know um
i had
you know childs being a kid you know we
grew up poor
in
a bad way
you know and then you always think the
grass is going to get greener on the
other side you know step parent after
step parent it never gets better
you know
but um
you end up
learning that no matter what your
parents try to teach you're instilling
you
that um
what they did wrong you don't have to
pay for forever
you know just let them be free of their
own mistakes
you know and i would think that about my
mom
a lot like
she hates herself
through and through and i think it's
because
um
because of the way she was brought up
you know
happened
you know
her dad was just as mean to
her mom you know
and i think [ __ ] ran downhill after that
you know my mom didn't know how to
cherish lebron or anybody not even
herself because she never felt loved
you know
and i think that's
why she is the way she is you know
favoritism
you know one over another it's wild
you know what's to
mad josie between all her kids you know
but um
i love my sisters more than
the
i mean i adore my
little sister
both of them
like
more than anything in the world no
matter what they're doing or who they're
doing
you know
i just hope that when and if i find them
they find
that i'm happy
you know my sister
my sister laura she's like
the only thing that i hope is that you
end up happy
was the last time you spoke to them it's
been a long time i wasn't allowed to
talk to my family my last um marriage
was
how if i tried to contact anybody or
wanted to go anywhere i wasn't allowed
to
i wasn't allowed to
do much of anything but now you're free
i'm free to be who i want to be you
don't want to contact them now
i do um
i want to have more of something
established you know
for whenever i yeah the situation you're
in now is not not anything that you
don't report back no what's going on now
yeah when did you come to l.a
about
i would say about four years ago
and
i found it um
rough in the beginning you know i
thought i'd be all
able to
handle you know homelessness and be able
to start this brand new life you know by
myself but when you're so used to being
in you know abusive kinds of situations
you you're used to being told what to do
so trying to make your own decisions
sometimes you know
you um
you try to make the best one
but
it ends up a little rougher than
what you intended you know
but it'll work out life will work out
you know
where you've been staying when you're
here um wherever i can with friends you
know the
friends that
you know i was just staying with um
i find
you know you meet new people every day i
do
and it's been good
you know um you have to do things that
you don't really want to do to
sometimes you know but hey it is we do
what we got to do you know especially
now that
you know i'm out here and
you know experimenting with all the
different
options that i have
you know we'll do what we got to do and
then eventually
um it'll pay off
you know
how do you generally how do you support
yourself
um i've
had to
be you know a working girl you know i'm
not going to say that i haven't
half the time you know
you do it
um
whether
you're in the
moment or not you know you do what you
got to do and that's why
i really want this you know i'm
wanting to
make a better way for myself you know
what what is your drug now
i'm crystal
crystal matt yeah
you know it's something
that you can do for fun
you know and then sometimes you feel
like damn i just gotta have it you know
but um
something that i'll let go of at the
right moment
but not now
to be honest i won't not at this very
minute but i'll work on it you know
is this the lowest point of your life
right now
it is um well
not right now i feel like i'm being
lifted up from it and the lowest point
in my life is you know being game raped
by a bunch of people you know and
um
that's what changed my life out here and
really made me not care about who i was
doing or what i was doing what's
happened where
um
here in l.a
it was horrible
um something that i won't forget but try
to get
past
you know
it'll work out
that's horrible yeah
yeah do you feel like life is unfair
i have at times
you know um given your childhood
yeah
marriages yeah i mean if you've ever sat
back and
you're like man i wish i hadn't been
born at all
you know
like what the [ __ ] am i doing here like
i can't make my parents happy i can't
you know half the time my siblings don't
like me
you know um
my husband is definitely it wasn't i'm
good enough for them one way or another
no matter how hard i tried
but um yeah that's why i said you know
i don't mind
you know um
someday i'll find that
right girl or whatever you know and my
life will be better
you still have hope i do that's great
yeah
what are you afraid of
um
i'm afraid that um
that i won't be accepted you know or
just being
who i am by
you know whomever i
end up wanting to be with you know
and but
as long as you know
i can't wait to go through the
the dating
fun you know
uh
getting a chance to meet somebody new
you know
so i do still have hopes you know
to make a
have a
good life
and
i'll get there i think it will
what emotions do you go through
living here um
i've gotten i cry sometimes you know
when
you know i think about being pain too
bad you know not having anybody to talk
to
i think sometimes makes it worse you
overthink things and
yeah but
um
in the end i'll find
solitude and happiness i believe
and that's all i want is to be happy
you know even if that means that i have
to spend
you know
just give myself a chance to you know
to find that someone
and
just stop looking for him i think
trying to stop trying to make people
love me
no matter what i'm doing you know i
can't force anybody to love me
so that's what i want to
quit doing
are you lonely i am yeah
i think a lot of us are yeah
they're very long
what is the hardest part of
living down here
um not knowing where to go for showers
and
you know like just the
the minimal necessities of life you know
you ask someone where to go and you're
let off in a different direction you
know and that's what happened to me
that's how i ended up getting
gang raped out here it's like i'm just
tired i want to shower you know do you
know where shower is he's like yeah i'll
take you go get you some clothes and you
can take a shower and then
helena and basket after that it's hard
being surrounded by all these hustlers
and con artists yeah
snakes
right
yeah that get that wears on you after a
while right they do
they sure do
where were your best memories in your
life
my best memories in life are
learning to dance with my dad
um to
a song that
i don't think i'll ever get you know
and um
what was the song
i'm leaving
on a drag plane
yeah i love that song
yeah
he taught me how to dance
he was wearing like
moccasins or something and he put me i
was maybe like
not even seven maybe and he put me on
his feet and he taught me how to do the
two-step it's pretty
cool sweet yeah he did the best for me
that he could when my mom got remarried
i was like all right i'm gonna go back
with my dad because you got a new
husband you got two other kids and i'm
gonna go you know help my dad so he's
not lonely
you know but he had
i had to witness him trying to kill
himself one time it was it was the
scariest thing i've ever seen in my life
um
i followed after him i was like where's
he going like i don't know what was
running through his mind but he had put
a bunch of rocks into his jacket and was
just gonna
walk into a lake and just sit there i
was like oh my god dad don't don't you
my best friend is literally
you know it was horrible the scariest
thing i've ever seen
that and
the way he treated my brother you know
i hated the way he treated himself and
hated the way it treated my brother
why do you think he was suicidal do you
think it felt
guilty
i think it was a lot to do with um
the fact that my mom left
you know and
he never got over that loneliness
although he i know he slept with
somebody else i was like dad you know
you did i was like why won't you just
get remarried he did
you know but
um
his love for her never went away and
that's kind of where i following the
same mistake
is
the same pattern as my dad is trying to
make somebody love me
that i never could
what's your biggest regret
um
not
being able to
just be free and do what i wanted to do
rather than doing what my parents wanted
me to do
it's hard to be a parent pleaser
and that was my biggest regret was being
a parent pleasure
[Music]
christina what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
um
that
regardless of
what i'm
doing at
any moment that
i truly am loved you know by
at least um
you know uh
at least by a friend
you know
it means having one friend
would be my
best moment is trying to remember one
friend one true friend that i've had
that would do anything and love me for
no matter what do you have any friends
now
i'm learning to you know make more
friends i think
you know
and so yeah
you know i've got a couple
and um as long as i
can learn to treasure them
and if they love me back regardless
then that's that happiness that i'd look
for is you know finding a friend that's
loving regardless you know
all right christina thank you so much
for sharing your story thank you thank
you very much
you